[موسيقى]
احد اسباب التدهور يوم 7/4 الرئيس ظهر
يعني امام العالم
وقال يعني قولا يعني المعروف مشهور اذا
اعتدت علينا اسرائيل او قصفت العراق او
الاردن اعتقد بوقت احرق نص اسرائيل هذا
ازعج الامريكان واقام الدنيا وما اقعدها
بعد يوم 13 بالشهر اخبرني قال انا كنت
بالموصل يعني فتره الربيع قال فاخبرني
سكرتير
قال لي وفد امريكي جاي والوفد يقوده
السناتور باب دول وطبعا بوب دول يعني كان
من السناتره من الصقور بباذنجون ماكين
وبزن
جون
يعني الاخرين
قال ارسلت لهم طائره الخاصه وجابوهم هم
اربع اشخاص وما امهم سفيره
[موسيقى]
اول ما يعني حدثوني كان بحده بعتب شديد
على موضوع التصريح انه ايش حرق نصف
اسرائيل
فايش كان مغزى
التصريح وهل انت جاد يعني بهذا التصريح
جاد بالفعل يعني ترجمه الواقع
وكان عندهم عده مطالب منها هيكله الجيش
العراقي انه دخلت
ب 15 فرقه وطلعت ب 60 فرقه ومنها لانه
يعني قويه كثيرا
بالحرب
العراقيه قال من عندك خمس قاده عرب من
جيران
[موسيقى]